وجه البيت الأبيض بعد ظهر اليوم
إدانة شديدة لتصريحات
اثنين من أعضاء
الائتلاف الحاكم لرئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي بنيامين نتنياهو،
وكلاهما وزير الأمن القومي الإسرائيلي
إيتمار بن جافير ووزير
المالية الإسرائيلي بتسلئيل سموتريتش، اللذين
دفعا علناً في الأيام الأخيرة إلى
فكرة إجبار الفلسطينيين على المغادرة.  "
غزة تضرب إلى الأبد قال سموتريتش هذا
على إذاعة الجيش الإسرائيلي، لن
نتقبل وضعًا يعيش فيه مليوني شخص
هناك، مما يعني أن الفلسطينيين إذا
كان هناك ما بين 100.000 إلى 200.000 عربي يعيشون في
غزة، فإن النقاش حول اليوم التالي
للحرب سيكون مختلفًا تمامًا."  م
من أجل تغيير الواقع في غزة بشكل كامل،
وإجراء محادثة حول
المستوطنات، ستحتاج المستوطنات الإسرائيلية في
قطاع غزة إلى أن تحكم هناك لفترة
طويلة، وهو اقتراح أطلق عليه زعيم
الحركة اليهودية الإصلاحية في
الولايات المتحدة، الحاخام ريك جاكوبس، اسم
التطهير العرقي وما  وصفته وزارة الخارجية الأمريكية
بأنه تحريضي
وغير مسؤول في مؤتمر البيت الأبيض اليوم،
وهذا ما
قاله المتحدث باسم مجلس الأمن القومي جون كيربي، إن هذا
البيان يتحدث نيابة عن
حكومة الولايات المتحدة وعن هذه
الإدارة من حيث أه
رفضنا الكامل وتوبيخنا لأي استخدام
قسري  تهجير
أي فلسطيني خارج غزة، لقد أوضحنا ذلك
لنظرائنا الإسرائيليين في
جلسات خاصة، بالتأكيد أوضحنا ذلك
علنًا، وهذا لن يغير
وقوف كيربي إلى جانب بيان
وزارة الخارجية هناك الذي يدين ما هو
كثير، كما قال رئيس الوزراء نتنياهو، بينير.
ومع ذلك، لم يدين
الوزيرين بسبب تعليقاتهما التحريضية
كما ناقشنا من قبل، بن
جافير وسموتريتش هما
متعصبان متطرفان مناهضان للعرب، ويسيطر كل منهما على
سبعة مقاعد في
البرلمان الإسرائيلي أو الكنيست حيث
تمتلك حكومة نتنياهو 64 مقعدًا من أصل 120 مقعدًا.
يتخطى نتنياهو هذين الاثنين في خطر
بقائه كرئيس للوزراء
منذ هجمات 7 أكتوبر التي نفذتها حماس،
بن جافير حتى وقت قريب، والذي
كان حتى وقت قريب يحمل صورة في
غرفة معيشته لإرهابي يهودي قاتل،
ويجعل الحياة أكثر
صعوبة بالنسبة للعرب.  والمواطنون المسلمون
في إسرائيل يوزعون الأسلحة على
ميليشيات المواطنين اليهود، ويتمتع سموتريتش حاليًا
بسلطات واسعة فيما يتعلق بالقضايا المدنية في
الضفة الغربية حيث قُتل أكثر من
300 إلى 300 فلسطيني في
اشتباكات مع الإسرائيليين، كثير منهم من
المستوطنين المتطرفين منذ
7 أكتوبر بعد أن شكل نتنياهو حزبه.
الحكومة منذ أكثر من عام بقليل سألته
عن هذين المتطرفين في
حكومته إس إم سموليتش ​​وصف
نفسه بأنه فاشي كاره للمثليين واقترح
زواج المثليين مثل سفاح القربى
النائب السابق آه مدير شينب آه
قال إنه إرهابي يهودي
حاول أن  لقد حاول تنظيم حدث عندما كان
الانسحاب من غزة مستمرًا وفي
ذلك اليوم كان يقول إنه كان
ينشر نظريات المؤامرة الفظيعة هذه،
لا بد أنك رأيت هذا بشأن
مضرب الشين واغتيال رابين،
أعني أن هذه تبدو وكأنها بالأحرى
الأفراد المتطرفون، نعم، حسنًا، الكثير من
الناس يقولون الكثير من الأشياء عندما
لا يكونون في السلطة ويضبطون
أنفسهم نوعًا ما عندما يصلون إلى السلطة أه
وهذا بالتأكيد هو الحال هنا
ربما كان هذا تفكيرًا بالتمني
لأنه لم يكن بيناف ولا سموتريتش
خففوا من حدة موقفهم على الإطلاق واتهم المنتقدون
كلاً من بينير أندريتش بإثارة
عنف المستوطنين ضد
الفلسطينيين الأبرياء في الضفة الغربية،
وتزداد الأمور حاليًا سوءًا
مع عدم دفع رواتب مسؤولي الأمن في الضفة الغربية
حتى الآن، وهذا بسبب
ما يسمى بعائدات المقاصة، هذه
هي عائدات الاستيراد.  وضرائب التصدير التي
تجمعها الحكومة الإسرائيلية لصالح
السلطة الفلسطينية وتعطيها للسلطة
الفلسطينية والسلطة الفلسطينية
تعتمد ميزانية السلطة الفلسطينية على
هذه الأموال بعد 7 أكتوبر رفض سموتريتش
وهو وزير المالية الإسرائيلي
تسليم هذه الأموال إلى
السلطة الفلسطينية.
الحكومة الفلسطينية هناك معرضة لخطر حقيقي للغاية من
الانهيار الاقتصادي وتلوح بصراحة
بشعلة المزيد من عدم الاستقرار بالقرب من
Tinder Box، وهي الضفة الغربية الخاضعة
للاحتلال الإسرائيلي الوحشي في
الأيام القليلة الماضية، وقد رأى الرئيس بايدن شخصيًا
أنه بحاجة إلى التدخل من أجل
التفاوض على هذا الأمر لإبقاء
السلطة الفلسطينية بديلاً قابلاً للتطبيق
لحماس، بما في ذلك إجراء مكالمة هاتفية مع بايدن نتنياهو
الآن، بينما تعتقد بعض مصادر إدارة بايدن
أن بايدن ووزير
الخارجية أنتي بلينكين وآخرين يمكنهم
الاستمرار في الضغط والحصول في النهاية على ما
يحتاجون إليه من
إدارة نتنياهو الأخرى  يقولون إن التوترات
تتصاعد خلف الكواليس لدرجة أنهم
يعتقدون أن الرئيس بايدن سيتعين عليه أن
يقرر في النهاية ما إذا كان لديه
ثقة في أن حكومة نتنياهو وأن
هذه الحكومة الائتلافية هي حكومة
يمكنه في النهاية التعامل معها
ليس فقط من أجل الحرب الحالية ولكن أيضًا
لما يسمى باليوم التالي في إسرائيل،
ما يحدث بعد انتهاء الحرب، لكن
بينما يركز الرئيس بايدن على
غزة خالية من سيطرة حماس وجيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي، فإن هذا
ليس ما تسمعه من
قادة إسرائيل، أخبر بن جافير
حزبه هذا الأسبوع أن  اقتباس الحرب هو
فرصة لتطوير مشروع لتشجيع
سكان غزة على الهجرة
إلى بلدان حول العالم مرة أخرى، وهو ما
يسميه النقاد تطهيرًا عرقيًا،
وكان رده على وزارة الخارجية التي تنتقده هو القول إن إسرائيل
ليست نجمة أخرى في
العلم الأمريكي، وكرر ذلك  رغبته في
اقتباس هجرة مئات
الآلاف من غزة،
قال لي مسؤول في إدارة بايدن في
مرحلة ما، سيتعين على نتنياهو
الاختيار بين الحكم بطريقة
ترضي بن جافير في
سموتريتش أو الحكم بطريقة
ترضي الرئيس بايدن
وإدارة بايدن رغم أنه من الممكن
بالطبع أن يكون نتنياهو قد اختار بالفعل